maintenant j'attends
trop d'hygiène tu l'hygiène
[Musique]
il faut plutôt se laver au savon tous
les jours mais sur les zones sensibles
vers les zones qui sont à odeur par
exemple les aisselles l'entrejambe les
pieds les mains là on utilise le savons
et peut-être l'eau claire sur le bas sur
les bras ou sur la peau des jambes par
exemple qui sont moins sujettes à avoir
de la transpiration et donc être
colonisé par des bactéries
[Musique]
si vous prenez du savon de marseille
c'est sûr que rambouillet avant tout les
jours vous allez avoir la peau sèche et
vous avez vous gratter par contre si
vous prenez gel douche ou des pains sans
savon là vous n'avez pas du tout de
dessèchement de la peau
[Musique]
si vous avez l'habitude de rester deux
heures sous la douche ça ne fait que
déshydraté un peu plus votre peau
[Musique]
mois qui viennent c'est une science
passionnante
si on en fait pas du tout on est malades
sont en fait trop en est malade et il
faut trouver le juste milieu entre les
deux
[Musique]